okay cool
all right so again i'm kenny mustani uh
today i'm here to talk to you about
graph data modeling with neo4j
so this is the agenda we'll be going
over today so what is a graph database
an introduction to graphs an
introduction to the label property graph
data model
we'll do an introduction to cypher which
is neo4j's
declarative query language we'll also do
a tour a live demo of the neo4j browser
which is how we actually interact with
the database over
a browser i'll do an introduction to
graph based modeling i'll walk you
through some of the aspects of
actually designing a graph for your
database
and then i'll go over some graph data
modeling guidelines things you should do
things you shouldn't do some best
practices and finally i'll talk to you
about how to offer
graphgis which is a project that we've
created to allow you to articulate some
of your use cases
without having to download the product
without any installing software
you create a markdown file and it
renders into a live
actual uh kind of like a white paper
proof of concept that uses
our database in a website so it
generates a website
with some queries cool
so first let's start by answering the
question what is a graph database so the
graph database is a nosql database that
allows you to
store and manage your data as a graph
and so if you're not familiar with a
graph is a graph is actually
just a data structure that has nodes and
links
so you have these nodes which have some
directed arrows
and those arrows are relationships that
kind of describe
the interaction between nodes so a graph
database allows you to easily
store and manage this kind of data
structure so as you see here there's a
little example graph here
we have you at the center and then you
have your friends
so that's a screenshot from our browser
so let me introduce you more to the
concept of graphs so what are what are
graphs
so these aren't breadths these are our
charts so
we have to disambiguate because a lot of
people call them graphs and
that is the proper name for that but uh
we like to say i need that these are
just exclusively charts so that no one
gets confused
okay so what what do graphs have to do
with with data
so here we have an example of a graph
and you see that you have some directed
arrows which have some labels on them
those are relationship types
and you have some people and you have a
book so these these actual
rectangles circle things those are notes
and the arrows are relationships
so here we have john who's a friend of
sally
and we see that sal is also a friend of
john and we see that both sally and john
have read the graph databases book so it
describes some
some model some abstraction of the world
and puts it into an easy way to
articulate
so the relationships provide some
semantic context for you to actually
describe
some arbitrary domain
now if we take that further and we
actually assign some key values
to these entities these objects we have
now
something that we can articulate more so
we have now added age
on sally and john's we see that john is
27 we see sally is 32.
on the relationship we have another key
value so we see the
date that they've been friends since and
we see too
some information on the hash red
relationship so we see that john read it
on february
3rd 2013 we see sally read the book
on february 9 2013 we also see the
ratings that they
gave it so we see john gave it a five
and sally wasn't so impressed she gave
it four
we see some more information about the
book so we see this is the graph
databases book
and we see the authors ian robinson and
jim weber
so how does this contrast to the
relational table model
so here we have two tables we have
customers and accounts
we have alice who's a record in the
customers table and we have a couple
accounts
and so the problem here is how do we
attach alice to
her accounts well if you're familiar
with
relational databases you know that
there's a third table in the middle
which we call a join table which joins
these records together
we'll call that customer accounts and so
we see here that we have
a mapping from alice to her accounts in
that table
so that's how you would do that do
something very similar in the relational
table world
so now that we've gone over the contrast
between relational and
the graph based data modeling let me
introduce you to what the label property
graph data model is
so that's kind of a mouthful but what
that means is that we actually have this
model that neo4j is based on that
sharply contrasts from other graph
databases and from rdf
we have our own kind of proprietarily
designed
data model which we call the label
property graph data model
it has four basic building blocks as of
today we have
nodes relationships properties and
labels
so i'm going to go over each of these
and kind of the rules
that apply to each so first we start
with nodes
and so here we have an example graph
and you see the blue circles those are
nodes
they can contain key value pairs uh and
they're used to really
your entities where you're going to
actually describe the interactions
between them
using relationships so some more rules
uh
nodes can contain properties which are
key value pairs
they're java primitives neo4j is written
in java it runs on the jvm
uh you can also have arrays which we
call collections
and null is not a valid value which is
an interesting
thing because on the graph you have more
of a semi structure
nodes don't have to have the same keys
on every node in a relational database
you
you have these keyboard these key keys
that are replicated across certain
database are
certain tables so you have these key
markers that are the same
so you have four keys you have primary
keys and they have this strict schema
that's enforced
you don't have that in the graph you
have a semi structure where not all
nodes have to have the same
uh so when you query a node and you're
looking for a property name
and it doesn't exist you get back out
so what about relationships so here you
have relationships which are directed
they exist exactly between two nodes uh
in our property graph data model you can
only have relationships that are
directed one way or the other
you can't have bi-directional
relationships as a rule
so here we have a couple example graphs
so here we have peter and his friends
showing that notes can have
more than one relationship we also have
peter and lucy we see that peter
is a friend of lucy and we see that
peter is also a colleague of lucy
articulating that nodes can be connected
by more than one relationship
and then self-relationships are also
allowed
here with the example is peter proposed
to peter or peter voted for himself be a
good example of
cell phones self relationships
so some rules about relationships in the
property graph
every relationship has a name and a
direction
so we have one type so we call a
relationship type
that exists between the two nodes uh
some of the things that it does it
allows you to structure your graph more
so for the example you have people and
then you have a relationship
between people can be something like
friends so if you wanted to find a
friend of somebody
you can start at a person node and then
you can traverse outward with that
relationship type
relationships can also often contain
properties just like
nodes so what properties on
relationships are used for typically is
to
qualify the nodes to give them some type
of
context or weight so for example
between two nodes if you were to
diagnose media symptoms you had
a diagnosis model where you had people
with symptoms and they wanted to see
what their afflictions are
and they're describing their pain from
maybe a symptom you can have
a relationship that has a valuable
weight that describes perhaps
how much pain
uh another rule is that uh no dangling
relationships are allowed so
you can't you can't delete a
relationship if it's connected to some
notes you actually have to leave the
notes or
vice versa so you can't have a
relationship hanging out there with no
note attached
and then finally we have labels and what
labels are used
to do is to group notes in your graph
together
so it parallels if you've used gmail in
the past you'll you'll notice a similar
feature where you're applying
labels to your emails so it's a very
similar
concept we allow you to categorize
groups of nodes within the graph
to give some meaning to them so the
example here is we have
the left person who's also an author in
the middle we have
book and to the right we have person for
people
so some rules about labels is that you
can have zero or more labels it's not
required
uh you can have as many of them as you
want they're used to represent roles
again
like a user a product or a company which
groups nodes together
and also it allows us to associate
indexes
into a certain constraints on that set
of nodes
so for example if you wanted to index a
property
of this set you can specify within the
person
index i want to or the person label i
want to index the property
name so it allows you to do that it also
allows you to assert
unique constraints so if you wanted the
user id
property to be unique on a user role
then you can also do that
so those are the four basic building
blocks of neo4j
in the label property graph data model
so you have nodes relationships
properties and then again labels
okay so now that you understand how we
actually store and manage this data what
it looks like what what are some of the
rules
let's go over a cipher uh so if you
remember from earlier
cipher is neo4j's pattern matching
language
which has a very sql-like syntax and so
this is how
most people want to interact with their
database how they want to actually query
data
but it's specifically designed for
graphs so you have the power of
a sql-like syntax which you may be very
familiar with but you also
have the power of graphs involved with
that
so how does that work so i like to say
that it's all about
patterns and what a pattern is it's
really a configuration in your graph so
here we have this pattern
where a is directly connected to b and
then c
we see that b is connected to c so this
describes some pattern
that exists within our graph
so what does that look like so here's
our pretty picture of
what maybe our graph looks like in our
database
and we see that same pattern here where
a is connected to
b and c and b is connected to c and
we're going through cipher goes
through the graph and it finds all
instances of this pattern
that exists and then returns it back so
it goes through all the configurations
and finds that pattern
so why is that useful well a b and c is
an extract
an abstraction but here if you're
querying an actual domain maybe
you have a b and c are actual roles or
labels that exist on the nodes so maybe
it's
if it's a movie domain you have some
movies you have some actors
and that allows you to find all these
things using some type of pattern
so how do we do this what what does the
query language actually look like
so we do it using text art if you're
familiar with ascii art
actually these pictures that you see
maybe on twitter or in chat rooms that
text that looks like an image that's
exactly how we thought about it when we
designed it
so here we have a directed to b as a
graph on cipher we have the text
it asks the a it's directed to b and so
that's how we describe the patterns
okay so let's let's look at an actual
real cipher query
so so here we have a real cipher query
which kind of looks like sql
but we're using a clause called match
and what match does is it goes and it
matches that pattern in the graph
and then in the return statement you're
just returning the notes here so here
we're looking for a's a or b are
connected in either direction so we're
not specifying a direction here
and then we're turning back those two
nodes
now if we wanted to specify an actual
direction you can do that as well
so here we have match the pattern a is
directed to b
and to return back a a and b
so again what does that look like so
here's our our pretty
example graph so you see the same
pattern here
so very very simple
so what about relationships so
relationships exist
in these squared brackets while these
nodes they're in parentheses
so the parentheses kind of describe this
little circle so node
and then the square brackets here
describe the relationship
and so these identifiers a and r
they're used to actually store the
results from a match
and to be used later in the query
so here we have two notes in one
relationship again and here we're
matching a is
directed to some other note we're not
specifying the note because we don't
need to use it or return it so we're
just saying
we want this pattern and then to return
back a
and then the property name and then
we're using a function inside for call
type which works around relationships
which actually turns you back the name
of the relationship
so an example of that if we had a
relationship type that we've named
acted in here we have actors who acted
in a movie
and that would look like this so we have
now this relationship type
any square brackets we use a colon here
to
separate out the identifier which would
be on the left normally
if you don't need the identifier you
wouldn't specify it but you still use
the column
and then a cypher query would look like
this so we have match
a the actor who acted in a movie and
returned back the actor's name
and then the title of the movie that
they acted
so you can also return back the
properties that exist on the
relationship
so here we have roles so what what role
did the actor play in the movie
and that exists as a property on the
academic relationship
so we're turning back the roles as well
so where it gets interesting is that we
have the concept of paths which are
these multiple hops out we have a
variable length reversal which you can
specify the range of how far you want to
hop out
and this is really powerful because it
allows you to do friend of a friend
queries so figuring out the friends of a
friend
which can be very complicated or complex
on relational database
we allow you to just specify a pattern
and then to return it that way
so here's the three hops we have a is
directed to b and then
b is directed c
so again before matching this pattern in
the graph that's what it looks like
you can also change the direction so you
can actually match any pattern a's
direct to b
and c is direct to b
again here's what that looks like
so now let's actually get into something
real so
if we had a movie domain again we wanted
to answer a question
so the question here we're wanting to
answer is who acted in a movie
and who was the director of that movie
so here's what that query would look
like
we have match a acted in m
which is after after the movie and then
we have another one which is d
directed m and to return back
the name of the actor the movie's title
the director's name
so just like before with a b and c we're
going we're finding
the labels that are applied to the notes
we have actors we have movies we have
directors
and we're matching this pattern in the
graph and returning
so what would the results look like
here we have tabular results that are
being returned so you see
that keanu reeves acted in the matrix
and the director's name that movie was
andy wilkowski
so we support aggregation functions as
well similar to sql some examples we
have count
they have min max average sum and
collect
we have many many more we have some
statistical functions as well
you can look online in our documentation
to get all of the functions that we
utilize for aggregates
so an example of using aggregates in
cypher looks like this we're answering
the question
which actor and director work together
the most
so here i'll break down this query we
have match
the name of the director and then we're
counting on all results
to get the count so improve c's together
so there's
accounts to duplicates a and d with the
proper name
and then it orders by that count
descending and then
limit by five
okay so let's talk a little bit about
graph traversals
getting from point a to point b or c
so we call this the all nodes query and
cipher so you have
match and return n which matches every
node in the graph
and then we have a where clause which is
used to as a constraint
say okay i want to match in but i only
want to get back
those nodes that have the property name
and
that property equals congress and to
return
back that node so this filters results
just like sql
but we allow you to do this in two ways
so we have something called the concise
syntax which allows you to specify
some key values in the match clause so
you don't have to use the where clause
where is still is not deprecated it's
still very valuable
for range operations and other things
but this is just a way to say okay i
want an exact match back on a couple
properties of the node
why is so why is that useful well if you
want to start somewhere
and then traverse outwards you have to
find that node first and so it's easy
when you're matching these long patterns
where you have this concise syntax
that says okay i have tom hanks now i
want to find all the movies that he's
added and then you can also add a label
so again labels are these roles where
you can have multiple roles associated
with notes
and we see here that we're looking at
the set of nodes within this graph we
can have millions of nodes in the graph
but if we just look at a subset in that
graph of actual
people then we're taking a smaller set
of that total graph so
we're decreasing the search space so
that we can actually
spend less time looking for things and
so that's why labels are powerful
and then from there you can top you can
use where clause
for combat name equals the comics
so again
okay so then putting these two
concepts together here you have the
label people
you have a person you have the label
movie so this match pause up here
you're looking for tom hanks tom hanks's
movies
so you're saying match tom with a label
person
and then get the relationship type acted
in and then
movie with the label movie and then here
we're using where
tom.name equals tom hanks and then we're
turning back the title of the movie
and then using concise syntax we only
need to use two lines we don't have to
use where clause
because we can actually specify the key
value
for tom hanks on name
so this makes it a lot more expressive
and there's some performance benefits as
well
so what does that look like so here we
have tom we're starting with tom so
we're getting the t
node first and then we're traversing
outwards from t
to the m nodes which are movies
so here we want to find all the
directors who worked with tom hanks
so very similar query uh we're breaking
it into two
patterns we have two triples here the
first triple is
we're looking for tom hanks and movies
he's acted in the first line
and the second line then we're also
specifying the comma
that we're reusing the movie identifier
and we're saying also get the director
that directed that movie
and so this is the final pretty graph
that i have to show you and then we'll
actually get into some code
so we have t and then this is the
traversal pattern that we're specifying
so we have t and then m's not specified
because we don't care about
that node we just care about the
directors who directed those moves
cool so now let's actually look at the
browser let's do a live product demo of
neo4j browser
first let me uh explain a little bit
about the browser
so in a neo4j browser uh it's basically
just a web-based shell
a reptile if you will it allows you to
execute queries over a browser and to
visualize results
so that's the basic rundown so we have
draft visualization bundled into this so
when you return nodes and relationships
you can actually play with that data
which is great to get started
you can also look at one of our
tutorials that's actually in the browser
that allows you to create
a sample data set which we looked at
today when i was explaining how cyber
works which is a movie data set
then again you can display this data
so let's go and take a look
okay all right okay so here's the neo4j
browser
and uh you see at the top here we have a
console this is where you type in
queries
we have history so if you hit
control up you can get a history of
previous queries
also you can run these queries so i'll
show you an example let's do some live
live coding here if i do the all nodes
query
which is match n turn in hit enter
that extra piece of cipher query goes to
the database matches that pattern
returns back to results
nothing in the database so no results so
let's let's change that let's go ahead
and add some data
so if you look here in the intro you see
that
you have jump into code with a mini
graph app
if i go ahead and i click on the movie
graph
it opens up this clutter little tutorial
which walks you through
a basic problem and how to solve it
using a moving graph so it walks you
through
how to solve the baking path which if
you're not familiar with
it's how you're related to somebody else
on the planet by how many hops
so if i walk through these slides here
i go to the next one i'm going to walk
you through all the tutorial
go ahead and you can click on this ugly
seat
ugly text and then you can that pops it
into the
console and you can go ahead and execute
this and it creates this movie graph
so now if i use the history which
control up
i can go back to the all nodes query
and i can execute it now we actually
have some data
so here you see a lot of stuff
but yellow knows our people and purple
nodes
our movies and the relationships between
them describe the relation between the
notes
and the labels so what if you don't want
to actually look at
this pretty graph and you want to
actually look at some
schema to see what's related and how
if you go over to the left here we have
these panels so you click on the star
which is your save scripts we have a
default in here which is what is related
and how
if i go ahead and click that it loads
this query
into the console hit play
and then we get italian result which
then you can just easily read
and see what's related and how for
example we have people
who have acted in a movie we have people
who have directed a movie
we have people have produced movies
wrote a movie
we have people who have who follow other
people and we have
people who have reviewed movies so
something very similar to imdb
that's the data set that we have in here
cool now let's try some of the queries
that we went over
earlier so if i wanted to find
all the movies that tom hanks
acted in i can use the concise syntax
so we're matching the person named tom
hanks
with the relationship type acted in
directed to m with the movie
later and then there's a couple things
we could do here in return statement if
we wanted to see some visual results
we can actually just return all
and then control enter to execute and
here
are all the movies that tom hanks has
acted
now if we wanted to show some tag
results we can just change that to
return back
mom his name and then
m dot type
then you get the tabular results two we
can see what roles that tom hanks played
in
these movies by adding r
on the relationship
and then returning back r dot rolls
which is a collection an array
so then you can see the role that you
played in the movie
so that's the basic idea of a graph
database neo4j
some examples of how you're actually
querying this graph data
so facebook social network is a giant
graph
that describes the behaviors between
people and people
what they like what they do where
they're at some pictures
and graph search allows you to just type
in something you don't need to know
query language and it
figures it out so here in this example
we have
the facebook graph search query which is
sushi restaurants
in new york new york that my friends
like
so what that graph might look like is
here you have
phil who's smiling and you see that
philip only has
two friends uh you have michael and you
have andreas
and you see the likes of andreas and
mike you see that
they like so michael likes high sushi we
see that andreas likes sushi sam
and we see that these restaurants here
that are in teal
they actually serve the cuisine sushi
and they're also located in new york so
that's the basic idea behind graph
search it translates this natural
language representation
into this graph
and so how would you do something like
that in cypher
so here we have the cycle query that
does this exact thing
and so we have we're looking for the
person named philip
we're getting phillips friends and then
we're seeing
all of the restaurants that phillips
friends
like and then we're looking at the
restaurant to see
first is it located in new york and
does it serve sushi and to return back
to the restaurant's name
so here's actually another pretty draft
so that type of query will then
translate that into a traversal and it
goes out and finds it
so that's just one real world use case
so now that i've shown you a use case
i've talked about cypher we've talked a
little bit about the graph property data
model
now let's finally get into how do i get
up off the ground and start
actually modeling my domain as a graph
so the first the most valuable
instruction that i can impart on you is
to start with a whiteboard
or a piece of paper but a whiteboard is
better
because whiteboards are easy to
articulate some domain and you probably
have done something very similar to this
in the past
so you can take this exact model here
and you can actually translate that into
a graph that you store and manage using
neo4j
so here we have an example of maybe a
social network
where we have two people adam and sarah
we see that adam and sir are friends and
we see some behavior from sarah
we see that sarah likes this piece of
content here that's called lol cat
we see that sarah also commented funny
on that piece of content we see that ad
originally shared it
so that is a property graph data model
itself so that can be
transposed directly into neo4j and then
you can query and ask questions on this
data model
like who are friends about them and the
content that they've
commented on and so that's the basic
idea behind starting
with a whiteboard now let's look at
another
domain the one that we are very familiar
with today
which is the movie data set so here we
have a whiteboard drawing
which you have actors you have directors
and you have movies
so you see the relationships between
these actors the movies that they've
acted in and
you see that both of these movies were
directed by
lanakowski being cloud atlas and the
matrix
so again that is a property graph data
model so you can take that and put it
right in the database and start querying
on it
so the next piece of advice i can give
you is to model incrementally
with a graph data model it's really
important to iterate your design
because you have these questions that
you want to answer you know maybe these
questions up front
but maybe you have the business who's
asking you questions
that you're not predicting that you
don't know yet you're not actually
accounting for these future questions
and so what a graph allows you to do is
to model incrementally fairly
easily as opposed to a relational
database
where if you wanted to add a property
you have to actually go through this
process and it's kind of
dirty if you're familiar with it but
there's really no easy way to do it in
relational
world but with semi structure like a
graph it's pretty easy just to add a
property
so here's our our movie graph again
and here's some of the some more
information that helped describe this
model so we see
that we have tom hanks and we have hugo
weaving at the top
we have some properties here like
nationality
we have the awards that they've won we
have again the roles that they have
acted in the movies that they they
played in
we had a genre as a property
and also on the director we have the
same as the people top so
nationality and the awards that they've
launched
so some graph data modeling guidelines
what do i do what do i what do i not do
so in a graph you have this problem
commonly you have
symmetric relationships where you have
uh for example here you have two people
in the relationship between them
you see that sarah is a parent of eric
and you see that eric is a child
of sarah and so
when you're modeling this out we ask you
to choose between one or the other
you can certainly use both but that
increases the amount of relationships
total that you're traversing in some
cases and so
it's really simple to actually just
infer these symmetric relationships
uh by saying one or the other and then
the cipher query
looks like this so in the case if you
chose parenthood for
all of your relationships between people
instead of childhood you would then
query
the same pattern but you just returned
different results so if i wanted to find
the child the match is
find sarah parent of child and to return
child
to find a parent it's match parent
parent of child and then just return
the parent
so what about bi-directional
relationships
so the example here you have is eric
knows ernie
ernie knows eric how do i model that out
if i can only have
one relationship that's directed either
way
well you would use a query that ignores
this relationship direction
so we ask you not to do this that's
redundant and unnecessary
and instead just use one of the other it
doesn't matter which just
use one of the other and then when
you're querying
for your nose relationship don't specify
a direction we allow you to do that
which will get either one
okay so what about qualified
bi-directional relationships so
what if you need you need to have
bi-directional relationships because
these relationships describe some
quality or strength
uh of the of the actual concept between
the two notes
uh well here we have the example we have
two people and we see that lucy
likes peter but for peter he loves lucy
and she doesn't reciprocate
um so to model that with actual property
you would actually have a strength uh
property on the relationship
which in your application layer you can
have a rule that describes
uh if what's the value if strength is
five does that equal up
in this case yes it does
another question that i get frequently
is properties versus relationships when
do i use
a property and when do i use
relationship
so here we have an example of a person
who has
multiple addresses associated with them
and so
here in this example here this giant
node which would be the center node up
here
we have patrick scott age 34 and we have
these properties which are complex
value types so we have home address and
we have work address
well that's probably not the best way to
go that's
more similar to rdf in the property
graph you would just
model that these addresses as nodes with
their own properties and have a
relationship
attached to those nodes
so when to use relationships
so you should use relationships when you
need to specify some weight or quality
of the connection between notes so
that's that's first and foremost
then also if the value comprises a
complex value type for instance an
address
then you're going to want to use a
relationship another example is if you
have
a value where multiple people uh share
that and that's
you're probably going to want to create
a node for that and then attach a
relationship
so for example if you have multiple
people living at the same address
that's very valuable to have as well
so some examples of that is find all my
colleagues who are level 2
or above in a skill which is a property
value
and that we have in common so that would
be something like linkedin as an example
so linkedin is based off of a graph
model as well
also find all the recent orders
delivered to the same delivery address
would
be a complex value type
so here's that linkedin graph model so
what we're trying to solve here is that
we have
this social network of people and we
have the
roles that they're in and we have the
skills that they have
i'm not modeling the actual other jobs
here but this this graph can't expand to
include that
but here we have ian lucy and bill we
see that they
share a set of skills uh java c sharp
neo4j and ruby
and we see in the relationship type here
has skill
we see the level that's associated with
that skill
showing how strong they are with that
skill how many times they've been
endorsed on a social network
and then also we see that they work for
the same company
so when to use properties instead of
relationships
so when there's no need to qualify the
weight or really of the relationship to
the notes then there's really no need to
use it
it's a simple value type like a color
then you just want to use a property
so some examples of that is that you
have these projects
on github that have been written by
contributors to my projects
and they use the same language which
would be a property value
so also we have this concept of
relationship granularity so if you're
familiar with graph databases you might
have heard of rdf
which differs a lot from the property
graph data model so you have these two
kinds of graphs
so here on the left we have this course
grain model
where all the relationship types are the
same so we have
people we have addresses we have other
people
that this person's connected to and
we're just describing that with
connected to
very generic and then you would qualify
on the properties of these relationships
to the right we have the inverse which
is
the fine grain model so in the fine
grain model you have
all of the relationships the extreme of
that is that all the relationship types
are completely different and they
describe more accurately the connections
between the people
or the addresses of the progress so some
examples here is the
the first thing here bought on ebay is
original type
i don't advise doing that but that's
just an extreme
example
so again if you wanted to qualify by a
property and you have
these general relationships it can be a
very good idea for
example if you have peter and the
addresses that are attached to peter
to just use address and then when you're
querying you can actually just specify
this pattern which is just
peter relationship type address and then
the addresses
and then you can then filter on a
property which qualifies it
here being typed so that is the
course grain and then the fine grain
has two different relationship types for
address you have work address
and you have home address so our
guideline here is that
in this case it's best to use both that
gives you the best expressivity with
cypher to be able to actually go and
query these things
uh you can use either report
okay cool so that's all the graph data
modeling guidelines i have for you today
but i wanted to introduce you to a
project that developer evangelists at
neo4j
have been actively working on to help
you kind of understand your data model
to see what other people
are doing if somebody shares a similar
domain or use case to allow you to go on
a website be able to find some
interactive kind of
white paper or a blog post the way i
describe it
that shows how they solve the problem
and maybe how it's different from yours
so we call this the neo4j raptures
project
and here we have this really another
pretty graph which
our intern made created recently
so we have gists and we have a use case
associated with the gist
we have a domain that the use case is
within
and we have people who have authored the
gists and then two we're
we're tracking uh the amount of time
somebody's tweeted this on twitter so
that's just
an example and so maze created an actual
graph gist of gists which is really
clever
so what about authoring a graph just so
first you want to start by articulating
your problem so you look at your domain
you look at your use case you articulate
it probably i've already articulated it
many times but so it should be fairly
easy for you to articulate that
in an actual kind of blog post format so
i'm going to go ahead
and pull up our graphics project page
so it's at gist.neo4j.org
and here you have a quick introduction
we have a video
which shows you kind of how to get
started how do i author
just and then we have some examples
so i'm going to show you an example i
created on bank fraud detection
using neo4j and so here's the basic
format of scratches
so you have some table of contents here
and then you start by introducing your
problem so just a quick
paragraph here zoom in
so you see the interruption that i have
is banks and insurance companies lose
billions of dollars
every year from traditional methods of
fraud detection
play an important role in minimizing
these losses however
increasingly sophisticated processors
have developed a variety of ways
to elude discovery both by working
together and by leveraging various other
means of constructing false identities
i'm not going to do that for the rest of
the gist but that just gives you an idea
of an introduction
so then you'll want to go through
explaining your scenario
some of the various aspects of your
scenario for this example i
took a white paper that was actually
authored by a colleague of mine
on this scenario and i turned it into a
graph gist
and so i go through i explain the
scenario and i talk about
how graph databases can help so exactly
how do i plan
to in this case identify fraud rings
which is uh an attribute of these
these actual the fraud in this first
party bank fraud
so here we have this graph data model
that i've constructed that describes
that so
here we see that we have various account
holders
and that they have some piece of their
identity is also a node so
for example we have an address we have a
social security number we have a phone
number
and these people these account holders
are sharing
some aspect of their identity and so a
graph database is
great because it allows you to traverse
to find these rings
using some pattern detection and then to
identify what's the risk involved
so you model out the domain of your
problem you put the entities there
required to answer your questions
and solve the problem and then you go
ahead and you author you create a
cipher data set our cipher query that
creates the sample data set
to allow you to well here's the
visualization of that graph after cipher
created it but then the point of that is
to run some queries on it so we're
allowing you to create this markdown
file that renders into this webpage that
creates a sharded
instance of our database and its most
current version and then you can write
some queries against that again included
in this markdown file
so here i'm answering the question i'm
saying find the account holders who
share
more than one piece of legitimate
contact information
so you can see that right here he said
jane
john and matt they live in san francisco
they have jane and match your
social security number so i want to
identify that with a query
and so we see here that fraud rings john
doe jane appleseed
and matt smith and we see that they
share the contact type address
and the size of the ring so then the
next thing is to
ask the final question which is to
determine the financial risk
of possible fraud ring
and the result is that it just takes a
bit of the previous query
but adds in the financial risks by doing
an aggregate on the sum of their bank
accounts that
they have in their credit lines
cool so that's the graph just project
cool so summary of grouches so introduce
your problem
explain the solution design and graph
data model it helps to
start with the whiteboard there
translate that into an image if you want
take a picture of it and then from there
translate that graph data model into a
cipher data
and then formulate some of these
questions that you propose to solve the
problem
and translate those questions into
cipher queries
that you can run against your graph and
see the results and then
the most important part of this is that
it allows you to quickly iterate
without too much overhead by changing a
markdown file and then
refreshing the page and you can iterate
through that and see
how changing a cipher query might impact
myself
again you can get started with that at
gist.neo4j.org
and that concludes today's talk so thank
you and i will open it up for questions
okay so any questions graph data
modeling
graph juice
so when you were uh graphing the movies
and the actors
yeah so say clint eastwood is a director
and an
actor uh would you label him a person
and a director or
i mean the actor and the director so i
think we actually have
yeah we actually have clint eastwood in
here i think it actually we actually
have an answer to that so
no so you would just have person be the
label in the sample data set we're not
actually applying
after as a label or you could do that
it's another subset
but i think here if we match on i think
aaron sorkin
so if i do person
name so whether or not their director
would just be happy
yes it would be a relationship type so
if you have
directed the movie
i hope
yeah it should be good um cool so in
this case
what you can do is use regular
expressions
so if i do where and then i do p dot
name
and then i do equal mark by equal and
then squiggly
i can actually do regular expression
pattern fine
sorry
defeat um but yeah i'm not going to
admit defeat screw that
okay so best i can do is to look at
all of the movies
so okay so you can actually open up this
tab here which shows you some
of the information like the relationship
types so
i was actually right first times
he acted in something and he wrote
something right i'm looking at the
single data set now okay cool
uh yeah so to you if you played one of
these you can say
correct it and uh that's just going to
pull up the sample query um
but yeah so what are what are some
movies that aaron's sort of social
network i don't think that's in here
he acted in a few good men and he wrote
i think
good
okay cool uh so we have the movie a few
good men now if i don't click on it real
quick
i can see there he is
aaron sorkin now in our visualization
you can't really
see it because they're overlapping but
you have it directed and you have an
active relationship here
and so that's that's how you would
differentiate between the two in this
data set but you could also use labels
as well
okay other questions
cool yes i see
a lot of ways to choose how to model
your data
like you can apply labels to things but
you can also
make relations to
a node which is actually a label like
for example i can label people with
being a director
or i can make a known director
to the node yeah direct for example
right one way to do pixel
i'll see with all your examples like
white particles
yeah you can do it this way you can also
do it another way
i think to know which which method to
choose
one thing isn't it important to know
what are the implications for
indexing and the speed of like finding
things back
right here can you say something about
that like what's the difference between
labeling something or connecting it to a
node which you use as a label
fragment so in that example
where you have again labels that mark
some subset of the graph that allows you
to limit
the amount the search space that a
cipher query is going to go over and so
that's the
advantage of using labels and that's
unique to neo4j
so in the rdf model you have this very
i think it's a course for fine-grained
model where if you're connecting
you have a link to every other node
which is exact
and so those are some of the differences
in traversals you can have
multiple relationships that are the same
and then you can qualify by property of
that relationship
and there's an inherent performance
advantage here in the property graph
data model
which you couldn't apply to the rdf
world because rdfs are just so
different as far as the way that they
work but i do see
we were talking about as having a node
as directed
we call that an intermediate node so if
you wanted to do something like a hyper
edge which is
a relationship that's attached to
another relationship we don't allow you
to do that
with the property graph data model but
we allow you to create a node
that connects two other nodes and we
call that an intermediate then you can
have
more relationships spun off than that
um how are things in the next four
months
you suggested to have
both the work address and the home
address as two
different types of relations
and to have a relation address with
properties home and work
yeah like i would think like i want to
just
take one of these hyperbole the letter
and then have my my graph database
figure out
how to index it so it can also quickly
find one of them like isn't it silly
that you have to manually say
that there's a work address and a home
address
that's particular like what would you
want to be honest
purely for like just i'm not brag at all
that
just doing it is purely
for the sake of uh speed of fighting
so this is this slide specifically this
best of both worlds is
really specifically for formulating
cyber queries so you have
you're a dba maybe you've created this
this loose optional schema
and you want to give business users who
might be creating cipher queries
uh a more expressive way of saying
certain things in the same
way but you can't express it still if
you don't have these
two extra relations right you can still
say
i want somebody uh i want
everybody who has this address
with where the time of address
the property has the property that's
where
it has the property that's titled right
so
there's two ways to formulate the cyber
query right so
if you wanted to get all address all
addresses of a person if you wanted to
answer that question
well if you just had a work address and
home address
then you have to specify both of those
within more
to separate with just having a dress
relationship type
you can get all the addresses and then
you can further filter that down
by the type so that's how you would use
this model
to do that but if you just wanted to
find the work address say your web
application in e-commerce just wants to
find
the work address or delivery address
then the central query can just say
you know person work address and then
address
as opposed to having a filter on the
type yeah
like so it's this is just for the
convenience of being able to write it is
absolutely about convenience yeah okay
that's just the guideline you don't have
to do that of course but it's showing
you that you can't
use both the core screen and the fine
grained models
question yeah
uh just quickly another thing that just
occurred to me is you could have the
address notes that would be address
labels and then it could be like peter
lives at address pdw totally
yeah it's a good way to represent it
i was wondering if you could have index
on relationships like say
uh peter has a thousand addresses right
um and you want to only the type work
addresses
and you have an index attribute of those
relationships to
optimize those types of queries it's a
good question
no we don't support indexing for
relationships because you would usually
start at a node
so you would index that node you would
then in that case if you
had that scenario
maybe your bill gates and you do have a
million addresses but
you would actually use an intermediate
node and then index on the intermediate
so an intermediate node is like this
idea of hybridge where you have
three nodes you have a person and then
the address is a node that they're
connected to and then
that's just under nodes you have these
three nodes connected by your
relationships and then you would index
on
the address to further create a subset
of that
can you have here um
um
um
i was trying to find some benchmarks
really compared against like
my sequel and other sql databases
and also against other graph databases i
couldn't find
many sources so how do you think that uh
varies against those other databases as
i imagined that neo4j must be good
for some situations but not so good for
other situations and
what cases do you think that neo4j is
better
against other impressions yeah so
the reason why you probably can't find
any benchmarks because
what a graph database allows you to do
is to do some difficult things
in sql easier so my sequel if you were
trying to do
this try to formulate a query which is a
friend of a friend
or just n steps out and ops you have to
dynamically generate that query to the
depth that you're looking for
right so the benchmarks they differ
depending on
the query that you're actually doing so
let's say it really depends on your use
case
we do have benchmarks for neo4j we have
benchmarks for neo4j
graph databases we have benchmarks for
cypher which is different than
our java api so they are available and i
can
they treat differently than those who
are highly connected
uh yeah so like clustering no they have
some nodes which
have a lot of relations yes
okay for execution planning yeah um
we don't have that available in cypher
today you can create
your own comparatively using the job api
i don't recommend that but
in the future we do uh plan to do we
have on the product program to take
advantage of
uh some of these statistical
distributions to improve query plan
execution
good question cool any other questions
so i said again which verticals find
maximum business of
database magazine which verticals
i mean which businesses like uh oh
some of the industries that use yeah uh
the questions so
if you go to neo4j.com
there's a new website that we recently
launched that
really when we ask ourselves what do we
want to articulate about our database
it's
really our customers so if you go to use
cases
here you can see some of the popular use
cases like network and data center
management
social recommendations identity access
management in geo
so i'll just go let's go to network and
data center management
so here you can just get more
information about some of the customers
that use
this use case specifically like hp is a
good example
and then you can also see some user
stories so all the resources are here
um those are the five big ones
kenny does this also have the email on
case study that
talks about performance uh actually they
were running on my sequel by the way
and uh that's an interesting use case
that talks about performance in fact
their use case was that there are
same-day delivery servers
and some of their physical deliveries
you know the truck taking advantage to
you know was happening faster than some
of
the
very random i see and they moved to
neo4j and those queries were written
back into the series
right it's essentially about connected
data you know wherever you have
connected data
um that's where you would see the
benefit of the graph database
absolutely thanks yeah so if you go to
shuttle which is
was acquired recently by ebay
you can you can look at the slides here
which uh kind of tell that story
also there's videos out there if you're
interested
more on that i can help you with the
resources
is there a question in that yeah
there are a lot of cases where people
already have a lot of data in
the relational databases but would like
to also perform certain graph queries
right so do you have any recommendations
for how to
in real time translate
rdpo's data into neo4j
so that it can be cool yeah so you kind
of want to use it as like supplemental
you know attaches to relationship
databases there's really
no way that we support that kind of
feature you actually
have to import it do some detail process
we have a lot of import options
uh we have online for offline important
and so for that example something i
might do is to create an atl
run that the data from necl
in memory on neo4j spin up an instance
and then start doing some queries
and then when you shut down an instance
then none of the data is persistent this
stays in memory that's the way that i
would probably approach that problem
any other questions awesome well
thank you so much for coming and
listening to me today
if you're interested in getting in touch
here's my contact info
and then i'll stick around for a little
bit for your questions